NARRATOR: From Yosemite's
iconic green valley,
to its secret eastern edge.
The little rain reaches
this arid landscape.
Blocked by over 13,000 feet
of solid Sierra Nevada.
An alien desert-like habitat.
Home to one of the
park's strangest females.
A praying mantis.
It's the last days of
summer in Yosemite,
and she's coming to the end
of her seasonal feeding spree.
Her main weapons,
prominent front legs lined
with shark tooth-shaped spikes.
The praying mantis is the
only insect on the planet
with three-dimensional vision.
Her lightning fast strike
clocks at 1/20 of a second.
But this is only a cricket
drumstick appetizer.
She releases a concoction
of alluring pheromones
into the air.
Oh do mantis.
One lucky guy picks
up the signal.
Maybe some eye contact can
smooth out this first date.
Or maybe not.
In exchange for his
would-be wooing,
the Casanova is attacked.
It's impossible for
him to free himself.
The male's head is ripped off.
The female's final main course.
It's an abrupt end
to a first date.
Or is it?
The decapitated male
is still moving.
The headless torso of
the male praying mantis
is still controlled by
nerves in the abdomen.
In a final mating act,
his body completes
what his head started.
The female, on the other hand,
is busy finishing dinner.
She'll mate with multiple
males each breeding season.
Not all of them will
suffer the same fate.
But the males who
are decapitated
may father the most eggs.
The ultimate sacrifice in a
unique Yosemite love story.
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]